[Music]
in the last video we studied about
inductive and deductive reasoning and
introduced the concept of conjecture in
this video we shall study how we can use
induction to prove that a conjecture is
true let's consider the following
expression this expression is a sum of
first end positive even integers where n
can be any natural number based on that
expression we come up with the following
formula 2 plus 4 plus 6 up to 2
multiplied by n is equal to and
multiplied by n plus 1 how did we come
up with this formula how do we know it's
applicable for any natural number n we
cannot check the reliability of the
formula for all the terms of the
expression one by one as it would be
very time-consuming in order to check
the validity of the formula for each
term we need a domino effect showing
that if the formula is true for one
integer then it will also be true for
the next and so on what do we mean by
the domino effect suppose you queue
several dominoes one after the other
how would you position each of these
dominoes in order to ensure that all of
them fall when you hit the first domino
logically we know how to achieve our
goal but how do we write it
mathematically the best way to achieve
your goal is 1 when the first domino
falls it will hit the second one and to
make sure that each domino will hit the
next one and each Domino that is hit
will fall when these two conditions are
satisfied no matter how many dominoes BQ
all of them will always fall similarly
in mathematics to prove the formula true
it has to fulfill two conditions the
first condition is a phat which is also
called as the base case the formula will
be true if P of 1 is
for n equal to 1 yeah n is equal to 1
represents the first term but what is P
P is a propositional statement that has
a definite value this value can be true
or false suppose we have the statement X
is cold then P of X can be true or false
depending on what X is
when X is ice P of X is true and when X
is fire P of X is false okay so we know
the first condition to prove a statement
true the second is a conditional
property also called as the inductive
step if we assume that the formula is
true for N equals K then it will also be
true for N equals k plus 1 thus creating
the Dominos effect which feeds spoken
about earlier it could also be thought
of as P of K implies the truth of P of K
plus 1 this assumption that we make the
assumption that the formula is true for
N equals to K is called as inductive
hypothesis to understand this better
we need an example two plus four plus
six up to two n is equal to and
multiplied by n plus 1 let this be P of
n now we will check the first condition
when n is 1 P of 1 has to be true let's
look at the left-hand side first when n
is 1 we will just consider the first
term so P of 1 for the left-hand side is
2 now we move on to the right-hand side
P of 1 for the right-hand side will be 1
multiplied by 1 plus 1 this is 1 times 2
which equals 2 therefore P of 1 for the
right-hand side is also equal to 2 the
first condition is done now for the
second one for the second condition we
first assume that n is equal to K so
what will be of K
equal to P of K is two plus four plus
six up to two K is equal to K multiplied
by K plus one based on that assumption
we have to prove that the statement is
also true for the k plus one case the
left-hand side of P of K plus 1 is 2
plus 4 plus 6 up to 2k plus 2 multiplied
by K plus 1 how do we simplify this look
at this part we have already seen that
this is equal to K multiplied by K plus
1 so we replace this part with K times k
plus 1 we see that the part k plus 1 is
common to both the terms hence this can
be simplified to k plus 1 times k plus 2
now to calculate the right-hand side we
replace the k with k plus 1 in this
expression hence we get the right-hand
side of p of k plus 1 as k plus 1
multiplied by k plus 1 plus 1 and that
gives us k plus 1 times k plus 2 hence
we can say that the left-hand side of p
of k plus 1 is equal to its right hand
side this means p of k plus 1 is true
and the inductive proof is now completed
hence by the principle of the
mathematical induction we can say that P
of n is true for all natural numbers N
[Music]